unter einem meer aus bunten
regenschirmen sind in münchen am sonntag
trotz strömenden regens zehntausende
menschen gegen hass und ausgrenzung in
der politik auf die straße gegangen
unter dem motto aus gehetzt gemeinsam
gegen die politik der angst hatten
zahlreiche unterzeichnet zu einer
bayernweiten demo aufgerufen darunter
gruppen aus zivilgesellschaftlichen und
kirchlichen verbänden der ehrenamtlichen
flüchtlingsarbeit gewerkschaften und
sozialverbänden schulen und
universitäten vier auftaktkundgebungen
hatten sich am nachmittag zu einem
gemeinsamen zug zusammen geschlossen und
waren zum königsplatz gezogen
ich will nicht aussprechen möchte gegen
den menschenverachtenden statements den
letzter zeit von führenden csu politiker
ans licht gekommen sind es geht so gar
nicht diese spielchen zwischen s&s die
sind unerträglich
das hat mit demokratie nichts mehr zu
tun das ist einfach persönliche
freundschaft und war nicht der meinung
dass millionen meist junger leute zahlen
müssen den preis zahlen müssen wir den
irrsinn der mächtigen und das stört mich
in ihrem aufruf wir hätten sich die
veranstalter insbesondere gegen die
verantwortungslose politik der spaltung
von seehofer söder dobrindt und co mit
der demonstration wolle man ein zeichen
setzen gegen den massiven rechtsruck in
der gesellschaft den überwachungsstaat
die einschränkung unserer freiheit und
angriffe auf die menschenrechte
zu den unterzeichnern gehören neben
bündnis 90 die grünen auch die
bayerische die linke und die münchner
spd
[Applaus]
[Musik]